now let's explore Pub sub a Google Cloud
asynchronous messaging service and API
that supports distributed
message-oriented architectures at scale
one of the early stages in a data
pipeline is data ingestion which is
where large amounts of streaming data
are received
data however may not always come from a
single structured database instead the
data might stream from a thousand or
even a million different events that are
all happening asynchronously
a common example of this is data from
iot or Internet of Things applications
these can include sensors and taxis that
send out location data every 30 seconds
or temperature sensors around a data
center to help optimize Heating and
Cooling
these iot devices present new challenges
to data ingestion which can be
summarized in Four Points
the first is that data can be streamed
from many different methods and devices
many of which might not talk to each
other it might be sending bad or delayed
data
the second is that it can be hard to
distribute event messages to the right
subscribers
event messages or notifications a method
is needed to collect the streaming
messages that come from iot sensors and
broadcast them to the subscribers as
needed
the third is that data can arrive
quickly and at high volumes
Services must be able to support this
and the fourth challenge is ensuring
that services are reliable and secure
and perform as expected
the name Pub sub is short for publisher
subscriber
or publish messages to subscribers
Pub sub is a distributed messaging
service that can receive messages from
various device streams such as gaming
events iot devices and application
streams
Pub sub ensures at least once delivery
of received messages to subscribing
applications with no provisioning
required
Pub sub's apis are open the services
Global by default and it offers
end-to-end encryption
let's explore the end-to-end pub sub
architecture
Upstream Source data comes in from
devices all over the globe and is
ingested into Pub sub
which is the first point of contact
within the system
Pub sub reads stores and broadcasts to
any subscribers of this data topic that
new messages are available
as a subscriber of Pub sub dataflow can
ingest and transform those messages in
an elastic streaming Pipeline and output
the results into an analytics data
warehouse like bigquery
finally you can connect a data
visualization tool like looker or data
Studio to visualize and monitor the
results of a pipeline or an AI or ml
tool such as vertex AI to explore the
data to uncover business insights or
help with predictions
a central element of Pub sub is the
topic
a topic is a named resource to which
messages are sent by publishers
you can think of a topic like a radio
antenna whether your radio is playing
music or it's turned off the antenna
itself is always there
if music is being broadcast on a
frequency that nobody's listening to the
stream of Music still exists
similarly a publisher can send data to a
topic that has no subscriber to receive
it
or a subscriber can be waiting for data
from a topic that isn't getting data
sent to it like listening to static from
a bad radio frequency
or you could have a fully operational
pipeline where the publisher is sending
data to a topic that an application is
subscribed to
this means there can be zero one or more
Publishers in zero one or more
subscribers related to a topic
and they're completely decoupled so
they're free to break without affecting
their counterparts
it's helpful to describe this using an
example
say you've got a human resources topic a
new employee joins your company
and several applications across the
company need to be updated
adding a new employee can be an event
that generates a notification to the
other applications that are subscribed
to the topic and they'll receive the
message about the new employees starting
now let's assume that there are two
different types of employees
a full-time employee and a contractor
both sources of employee data could have
no knowledge of the other but still
publish their events saying this
employee joined into the pub sub HR
topic
after Pub sub receives the message
Downstream applications like the
directory service facility system
account provisioning and badge
activation systems can all listen and
process their own next steps independent
of one another
Pub sub is a good solution to buffer
changes for lightly coupled
architectures like this one that have
many different sources and sinks
Pub sub supports many different inputs
and outputs and you can even publish a
pub sub event from one topic to another
the next task is to get those messages
reliably into our data warehouse and
we'll need a pipeline that can match Pub
sub scale and elasticity to do it